[Musique]
à Cusco on aime faire la fête c'est la
saint Sébastien alors c'est la fête de
la paroisse correspondante qui va
continuer tard dans la nuit
mais il règne une étrange atmosphère
dans le vieux centre colonial il n'y a
pas de touristes les hôtels sont vides
les restaurants les marchands artisanat
n'ont plus de clients qui vient à
couscous suivi vers le Machu Picchu en
train bien le train le voici immobilisé
des rails ont été sabotés la vieille
citadelle incarne joyau du Pérou va
rester vide pendant on ne sait pas
combien de temps c'est une catastrophe
pour tout le monde et pour ce chauffeur
touristique
c'est dur pour ma famille et tout le
monde ici mais il faut dire que l'argent
du tourisme s'en va à Lima il ne revient
rien ici c'est
provoquaient bien sûr des annulations et
les réservations pour la saison
touristique européenne et
nord-américaine devrait entrer
maintenant mais n'arrive pas ça va
prendre au moins trois ans pour que les
gens reprennent confiance non
donc c'est un peu
dommage non quand on voit la beauté de
l'endroit non
les affrontements ont été violents il y
a eu un mort par balle de fusil des
commerces ont été saccagés du jamais vu
ici
samedi soir des centaines de couscatio
sont brisés la trêve et sont allés
manifester sur la place d'Armes à la
mémoire des 46 victimes du soulèvement
depuis les 7 décembre dernier c'est des
paysages et moi moi aussi je travaille
dans les touristes moi je suis
terriblement touché mais ça me touche
plus la mort des paysages
[Musique]
ils savent que la police de Lima a
enfoncé le portail de la grande
université sainte Marcos qui hébergeait
des manifestants venus du sud pour la
grande marche 200 arrestations cette
violation de l'autonomie de
l'institution provoque la colère des
étudiants de tout le pays qui menace de
descendre aussi dans la rue
Kuzco vient de connaître deux jours de
calme de répit la caravane de Lima est
sur le chemin du retour déçu et quoi
qu'il arrive à Lima après la prise de
l'université San Marcos des
manifestations sont déjà prévues ici
pour demain et on ne sait pas pour
combien de temps Jean-Michel Leprince
Radio-Canada Cusco